good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday hope
everyone's having a great day um i am
joined last minute switch up you know
here at the morning toast we respect
mothers and that means that sometimes a
mom can't make it and brian kelly aka
the points guy has to sub it brianna
marla brianna marla is here thank you so
much for doing this on such short notice
the toasters really respect and
appreciate you what means the world to
me to be on your emergency dial list it
means the world to me to have you here
that means a lot
you just double mean the world yeah no i
sent it right back to you yeah i wasn't
prepared
because you can't say you can't say it
thrice then you lose the effect brian's
favorite song in the world is you mean
the world to me by tony braxton i
wouldn't say it's my favorite think
twice celine dion being twice celine
dion um but everyone listening listen to
tony braxton uh you mean the world to me
uh uh trish yearwood she's she's in love
with the boy that's a great one for
memorial day weekend we're just starting
you off with the bops of bops together
again janet jackson and always iconic
always iconic tune um we'll share our
playlist with everyone we've got a
really good lineup of songs it's a
perfect mix of like pop and gay anthems
and some mary morris i love me some
marriage ryan is a marin maurice girlie
have you met her
no i was at the us open she was sitting
behind me in the emirates suite that we
were at such a nice suite and um she was
sitting next to lupita and i felt so bad
for her because they were going around
the crowd with the celebrity cam and it
was like lupita and then marin was there
and then they just moved on to someone
else the disrespect the nerds it's the
bones
now we've got a great show for you guys
today brian's here so we switch things
up a little bit we have the fast five
um we also have some travel news and
since we're coming up on like a really
big travel weekend we need brian's input
if you guys are traveling near far
wherever you're going this weekend
listen to this episode before you go
because brian says he's got some hot
tips for the girlies i'm going to save
the girls so i'm going to save the girl
some money
some stress some energy and then we also
have deer toasters it's wednesday so
brian is going to help us guide you some
of our troubled toasters we're going to
guide you to a better place aren't all
toasters trouble deep down i think if
you are a toaster it is then inferred
that you are deeply troubled
i think that's a good statement now
before we dive in to the show we
just have to talk about the absolutely
horrendous it's like i really debated
even doing a show today um
uvalde texas mass shooting at an
elementary school i think it's up to 19
kids now two adults i think it's in the
20s or yeah it's 24 or something it just
keeps going up and i i just want to like
turn it off but no and it's like at this
point it's like feel so routine
that you don't even know what to say
anymore because everything you see
there's been more than one mass shooting
a day so far in 2022. it's so disgusting
it's so horrible and like you see the
pictures of these kids faces and it's
like
it's just every it's horrible and
i really debated doing a show today but
you know here at the toast we try and
you know make people happy and i think
this is a time where people are really
feeling like so down um
so we're gonna do our show and try and
like bring a little light to what is
just a horrible week here in america and
just a true low point in our country
um and that's what we're trying to do
here so without further ado here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
now brian today's stories are bleak they
are not very exciting i try to tailor
them towards you because i know you're a
big housewives girl so we've got some
theresa news we've got some travel news
you mean tree tree tree my daughter's in
tree we've got some bleak stories but i
always forget are you a tree hugger no
are you no oh obviously we're margaret
fans
like to the dead by the way margaret
joseph's i'm just blown away i know we
love her i was watching like on i think
faces by bravo's doing a villains of
real housewives so and he's pitting up
random people is margaret a villain
literally and she was 70 of people voted
for her grant i think she was up against
someone moronic right but
people think she's a villain so me and
jackie say this all the time when we're
recapping jersey like we're definitely
biased because we know margaret on a
personal level and can attest to the
fact that she is margaret's a girly girl
beyond words beyond words she is every
caring generous really lovely like not a
mean bone in her body so are we just
biased or like is it crazy that she's
considered a villain
i think it's crazy i think it's crazy
too right yeah i mean the whole cheating
rumor is it is kind of a bomb to throw
but like but they were out there already
and there's another one today really bad
there's another louis story today
whatever his name is louise lewis yeah
there's a new story about him yeah he oh
it's the first story he allegedly pushed
his ex-wife into a metal pole
yeah he's deeply unwell he's deeply
problematic and sorry margaret's the
only one out there so let's dive into
the first story which is brought to you
by caraway
caraway um home it's time to ditch the
chemicals with caraway homes non-toxic
cookware and bakeware collections so you
can make healthier cooking a piece of
cake caraway homes non-toxic
kitchenwares are all designed for the
modern home and they feature a
chemical-free ceramic coating so food
can be prepared with peace of mind that
no hard-to-pronounce compound will leach
into your healthy ingredients so they're
non-toxic they're super easy to use and
they're eco-friendly which is just a
fabulous fabulous thing they offer the
cookware set which is a modern and
chemical free iteration of the
traditional 16 piece set but it's boiled
down to just the essentials a fry pan
saute pan saucepan and a dutch oven they
also have the bakeware set which is an
assortment of non-toxic baking
essentials that every modern kitchen
needs so you can get to baking without
any of the bads also their sets come
equipped with storage solutions so that
there's no stacking required like if
you've ever tried in your new york city
apartment to stack up frying pans like
you just know
lids get lost but they've got a system
at caraway visit caraway home.com
tmt to take advantage of this limited
time offer for 10 off your next purchase
this deal is exclusive for our listeners
so visit carawayhome.com
tmt or use code tmt at checkout caraway
non-toxic cookware made modern all right
let's dive into some of the idiotic
stories there is new allegations about
theresa giudice's fiance louis ruelas
allegedly he pushed his ex-wife into a
metal pole
so marissa dimartino that's his ex-wife
he's being accused of pushing her into a
metal pole during a heated argument in
2012 according to a police report
exclusively obtained by page six
his ex-wife reported that after her
estranged husband dropped off the
children the two began arguing over
finances the dispute became heated and
culminated with lewis pushing his
ex-wife into a metal support pole into
the garage the report was filed in 2012
one day after the alleged incident and
it continues to say that this action
took place in the presence of the
couple's son
his ex-wife refused medical attention
and was adamant that she did not wish to
sign a charge
um so things are just getting like worse
and worse
for mr lewis i'm going to answer it like
tree
why are you trying to pop my love bubble
she's i'm going to be cringing why are
you popping my love bubble she sounds
like a 16 year old in love for the first
time you know what in a lot of ways i do
believe that teresa is she's in love
with the boy she's in love with the boys
what's that naughty boy
theresa is stunted in a sense like she's
really she's like i've been through it i
see why she wants this piece her new
home actually i'll give her props that
old home was horrendous that old home
was twisted
like deeply unwell deeply unwell so
brown and cream like it was weird but
you know what i found out you know louis
is like a lot of money is it i feel like
i'm pronouncing his name wrong luis
louise
louis louis sorry sorry i got confused
louie so louie you know how theresa's
been adamant about not signing a prenup
and even andy during the reunion was
like please i'm like begging with you
just like look into it and she's very
against it and that's because like yes
she does he has money yeah
the company that he founded it's like
real estate or something right it went
public really so yeah he took it public
it was his company and he's obviously
been asked to leave but i don't think
you know he needs that job
so tree is not so dumb yeah but this is
concerning this kind of stuff
you know
yeah i mean domestic violence in front
of a child it seems to be pretty
documented however
you know
she doesn't want to see she's happy her
kids are grown mostly so hopefully do
you remember i don't think her daughter
her daughters wouldn't take any of that
for a second
he probably you know had some troubled
times
it looks like he wanted to get some
self-help yeah that retreat i mean
do we get just give them a pass i don't
know no but do you remember last season
when margaret was opening up about the
fact that you know in the workplace she
was like sexually assaulted and theresa
basically was like i would never let
that happen to me yeah it's like you're
kidding right it's not something you can
control right um
so i'm actually
i mean you're shook by this story based
on what happened in the taxi oh my god
you know what you were a whisper away i
was literally in my
sleep last night thinking about this
incident i talked about it on my
instagram like long story short i got i
took like a really uncomfortable
situation and nothing happened to me but
like i was i felt like i was really
close to like a dangerous situation and
i got out i think my biggest question
for you is why are you taking taxis okay
this is what i get because i have to say
you and ben's taxi race home from
marquis was premium premium so i
i actually like taking taxis first of
all because
they're they're better drivers like they
know how to maneuver around the city
better than anyone well i would agree
better than uberx uberx people are
problematic they're not the best but i
think just like in general yellow taxis
are cheaper you can pay with cash and
like paid with cash claudia
what why would you pay with cash oh
right sorry oh my god i forgot but like
[ __ ]
step forward four steps back sometimes
decides not to wait for the credit card
machine you know you just like
i know whenever i take taxis i always
leave thinking it's an uber and i get
like screamed up so my uber was taking
forever i was in like a really
trafficking part of town and this cab
just came right across so i cancelled
the uber and got in the cab
and his doors were like
really janky he had to get out and open
it for me he's like sorry my doors don't
work but you know you don't think
anything of that like this is new york
everything is broken in new york so i
get in the car and then he just starts
being really inappropriate you know like
telling me i'm beautiful asking me if
i'm single
um telling me he's been reported for
sexual harassment so i start like
getting so hot i'm like sweating and
like time is moving so slowly and i
thank god there was traffic because i
was like sir you know and i'm actually
just going to get out and walk it's a
nice day something you've never said
once before which is honestly like a
dumb question in the first place like
that's what i get
um
and
he had made me pay cash so like i don't
know it was just nothing happened to me
but like and it could have been a
totally fine situation but no
i think in this day and age you can't
you know
there's a lot of things going on in new
york right a man was just shot on the
subway like
yesterday in new york i had to go to atm
and i'm in there and it smells like meth
not that i know what that smells like
but it was something funky going on and
then they were like passed out homeless
people and i really needed cash i was in
a rush i'm an idiot and actually kept
trying to get cash with my eye on them
well now a lot of atm vestibules have
security yeah it's just like which they
should this one i i was an idiot i was
like i'm so dumb i'm so lazy i should
just walk across the street right
meanwhile the atm didn't even work and
sweating in the vest but yes you have to
be alert in this day and age in this day
and age especially you know places like
new york i mean across this country it's
everywhere you've got to have your wits
about you and when something doesn't
feel right you got to eject so i'm proud
of you for so you have to trust your
instinct even if you think you're being
crazy like better to be overly cautious
absolutely so i was just like in a deep
state of panic all day yesterday but
back to tree like i do believe that
these allegations are true like there's
a documented history 2012 but you know
tree wants what tree wants and she's not
going to let anything get in the way and
frank was on the show he said they're
getting married this season so he thinks
it's in the summer he's not invited um
so nothing is going to stop this wedding
she's been presented with information
but she's confused
but this is america and she has that
right to do whatever she wants and and
she's moving full steam ahead yeah she's
a girl in charge that's an iron love
bubble it is it is an iron clad love
bottle um all right next story a little
spooky psychedelic news so will smith
saw his career being destroyed in an
ayahuasca trip before the oscars
so he's doing um david literally four
hours before the oscars he was on
ayahuasca
that would make a lot of sense that now
things are adding up so before the
infamous oscar slap will smith had a
vision of his career his home and his
family slipping away from him while he
was tripping on the psychoactive drink
ayahuasca so the king richard starr
recalled the experience to david
letterman and david letterman's new show
my next guest needs no introduction it
was taped before will smith smack
slapped chris rock on stage during the
academy awards telecast so he told david
letterman that he began to notice a
subtle sickness involving an addiction
to material success
around the time i am legend was released
in 2009 he sought to remedy himself by
taking a break from work and not
speaking for two weeks
smith said the same experience taught
him to live with the reality that any
moment anything can be gone in a second
but he continued looking inwards he took
14 journeys on ayahuasca in peru over a
two-year period and he called it the
individual most hellish psychological
experience of his life i started seeing
all my money flying away my house is
flying away and my career is going away
and i'm trying to grab for my money in
my career and my whole life is getting
destroyed claudia you saw that happen to
you and you didn't even need ayahuasca
good one very good sorry continue no i
like that
so he saw this happening he said i hear
a voice saying this is what the [ __ ] it
is this is what the [ __ ] life is and i'm
going oh [ __ ] and i hear willow
screaming daddy help me daddy help me
come won't you help me and i'm like i
don't see you so basically people are
now like quaking that he
literally most things in his vision came
true like netflix you know they pulled a
lot of his projects the academy award i
think banned him for 10 years so um
maybe we should all do ayahuasca and see
the future i
promise you i will never do ayahuasca
with
you [ __ ] literally like i'm so deeply
unwell
that i really am not like i'm not cool
on drugs like i'm not so i know everyone
talks about ayahuasca like i don't know
life's pretty good i don't i don't need
a reboot like what hap i know someone
who did like frog poison
and she's like i kind of need a support
group for the rest of my life really
because sometimes you might see things
you don't want to see no and like i
watched you do you ever watch the goop
netflix show the one in jamaica well
they like every episode yeah so they it
was like a yeah it was a mushroom tea
like yeah and these people are crying
they're in the fetal position and then
afterwards they're like that was amazing
like nothing is worth that well i
actually think so governor rick perry of
texas just came out recently who we've
met before
and he's and uh apparently for veterans
i do believe there's so many amazing
powers of psychedelics for ptsd for
veterans 100 so i think we as a society
need to harness the power of like
natural medicine way more
great but we need to see like clinically
people are like out in mountains like
with all these like you know spiritual
and now it's like now everyone wants to
do especially after what was the 10
perfect stranger no the show with nicole
strangers non-perfect yeah
so yeah be careful out there going to
places would you ever do ayahuasca i
mean i would never say never i know a
lot of people but um
yeah i mean i would maybe i would
literally never do it yeah i don't think
i'm the right person for it yeah too
type a
i can't like con like let go of control
of my body i can't imagine you doing
something that like has a high
probability of you [ __ ] yourself
can you imagine you have to no do you
[ __ ] yourself on ayahuasca yeah
apparently in puke like it like expunges
all of this stuff out not everyone but
like
you would like in a mountain like was
just duty no like you can do it in
brooklyn now they have like sessions
brooklyn upstate new york like you can
go and like it's a guided
situation where you're like convulsing
on the floor i do believe it works for a
lot of people but personally i'm out
like never never will be me yeah scares
the [ __ ] out of me yeah but i definitely
believe in some of the powers like look
will smith literally saw his whole life
flash before his eyes but if he's done i
asked for 14 times why didn't he stop
that from happening that's true he was
his own as roo would say in her saboteur
yeah totally i have not started the new
season of drag race all-stars
but you're gonna have to rewatch it with
me this weekend you know that right i
think it's great talent but it's you
know what i'm so upset with rupaul
lately it's like everyone gets a
participation medal oh my god oh and
this season two episodes nobody goes
home um
not only that no one gets a singular
piece of constructive feedback
you're great
stunning
even michelle visage who's like the
simon cowell of drag
you mean the world to me like like every
single person is the best they can be
participation metal city i hate that
like you have to be so
brave these days to like be critical i
mean it is good talent so that's true
it's also all-stars like there there's
really no bad there is feedback oh i had
lots of feedback but
you're gonna have to re-watch it with me
this year
i'm very excited and also we never even
got to talk on the podcast about our
experience seeing rue in real life
two weeks ago our la weekend
like if i think we should like we should
do a blog post of like this is how to do
la right out of control right here's how
to do la wrong
we love the west hollywood edition
marriott property oh my god major
amazing spa points
pool restaurant la edition and the labo
products
full size full lobby
great for
it's good for naps good for naps great i
took great naps in our lives and i've
long like been another lobby oh yes i
did fall asleep in the lobby after a
couple cocktails um i've long been
searching for a good hotel in l.a yeah i
like it i love it like i don't think
i'll stay anywhere for a point hotel
like that's it's it's a good location
so uh dinner we ate craig's craigs is a
joke so good
we ate at nobu malibu
so
so we go to nobu malibu the most
expensive restaurant in the history of
the world but actually we ate at soho
house malibu which is next door two
hours prior yeah but i was i couldn't be
stopped yeah so brian was like i'm full
avocado saturday we went to horses which
is a new shiki
good they had a great pasta we really we
yeah our friends birthday party at
chateau oh yeah we were being fabulous
like we were being we're seeing queens
we were having like our paparazzi moment
even though there was not a paparazzi in
sight yeah well not for us anyways yeah
well there were fans at craig's but like
they didn't approach us in front of
paparazzi right they like waited to be
discreet we're like no approach in front
of them trigger them
because we manifested we will have our
paparazzi moments in 2022. and i got
really close earlier in the year um we
went to craig's in january in february
and there was a paparazzi outside and he
was like claudia and i was like yeah
he's like how are you
i'm like oh i'm good how are you
chatting me up chatting me up i'm like
uh okay i guess you could picture me or
not no and then i went inside so like
i'm on that's that's how close
and then this past time at craig's you
had a lot of fans outside and the
paparazzis were looking down and all
your fans were really nice for once in
your life they were not their sponsors
i'm like this is the time to be at this
moment come on girls i'm such a stage
mom they were civilized come on girls go
crazy
instead don't come up to our table
do it in front of the paparazzi as i was
walking by they're like i don't want to
bother you but i love you i'm like no
[ __ ] bother me this paparazzi louder
louder come on girl faint do something
devastating not to make everything about
us but will smith good luck to you sir
um all right next up our third story is
oh some kardashian news um your favorite
person in the world caitlyn jenner
is saying she wasn't invited to kourtney
kardashian's wedding in italy so she
didn't make the cut for kk and tb's
wedding in italy sources close to the
couple told tmz and by the way if it
comes from tmz that means it came
straight from chris jenner's mouth told
tmz wednesday that the kardashians
former step parent never received an
invitation in the mail in the very
intimate wedding weekend because they
have a very limited relationship so tmz
noted that kardashian and jenner do not
really see or speak to each other so the
push founder did not feel it necessary
to invite the former olympian to her
destination wedding sunday
i'm totally yeah team uh courtney on
this caitlyn's an ass she is like and
caitlyn is deeply unwell i think how she
her whole experience and how she really
kind of
was so rude to chris and threw chris
under the bus in her show 100 which i do
i download all my shows because i watch
so every time i open up itunes like i am
kate is like randomly there i'm so
embarrassed like it's like when you have
to block your like laptop from someone
some people do that in case there's porn
on their computer mine is like i'm so
embarrassed that i am kate is on my
itunes library and itunes is turn they
like know your most twisted shows that
is embarrassing you know what my first
one that comes up because it's with an a
and it's so embarrassing
i don't even think you've ever heard of
it alan gregory no it was a one season
cartoon show written by jonah hill where
he's just like really like sassy
elementary school kid and he has two
dads and it's so funny brian like you
will love it like it's everything my dad
is really really rich and like one dad
is really really hot oh that's kind of
funny it's really good um well i just
had to plug my favorite show in the
world uh locked up
locked up abroad is so good each and
every single episode too much of it
brian i know i'm afraid i'm going to get
locked up abroad like manifest good for
your mental health no but it's so good
you were in newark and like they had to
do extra screening oh my god so get this
story i didn't i've been told anyone i
didn't put on social so i've been
critical of the government like right
now like the government and covid
testing rules you can fly in the us
without a mask
no testing right but if you go to europe
canada where they have coveted way more
under control coming back you have to
get a cova test it's so expensive and
stupid so i was like kind of dragging
the government for a while tagging like
potus and budapest not that they care
and then so i come back and i'm watching
locked up abroad flying home from st
bart's which is really fabulous and then
i go to the global entry machine and my
first time in 15 years i get an x across
my face
and i go up to the guy and i'm like okay
this is weird i'm sure he just needs to
verify maybe it didn't take a good
picture
the guy goes
oh no you got to come back with me sir
he comes out from behind the booth
closes the lane and takes me back takes
my passport gives it to like a police
officer and i'm in a back room oh my god
i'm panicking like you're literally like
what has happened what do i have on me
no like no but you're detained because
you are literally like slandering the
government i mean are we living in
russia
is this a simulation literally so what
ended up happening so they ended up
coming up and the guy asked me a bunch
of questions what do you do where are
you from
and he's like okay i just had to verify
there's a
and this is what i think happened so
after 9 11 there's a brian kelly terrace
in ireland on the ira you're kidding me
my dad in 2001 my dad actually wasn't
able to travel like he literally your
dad's name is also brian kelly for those
of you my dad had to go to our senator
and get our names cleared from the
homeland security list so the guy said
there's someone named your name that's
now on the list so i've traveled since
and i think it's fine um i also think my
global entry expired i had to renew it
so i'm just going to start with one of
my tips yeah the girls out there
for toasters and boys too of course get
global entry if you don't have global
entry today get it get it get it it's a
hundred dollars for five years and what
global entry does when you come back
from the us right now there's huge
staffing shortages with immigration yeah
so it's
uh global entry and then everyone else
and you can wait three hours in line so
global entry
allows you to get through in 30 seconds
i consistently get through immigration
in 30 seconds but it also includes tsa
pre-check which is a must-have because
the tsa also is so crowded airports are
packed having pre-checked is like clutch
so instead of paying 85 for pre-check
you pay 100 for global entry and there
are a lot of credit cards sapphire amex
platinum that will give you global entry
for free
um and it will just save you so much
time a lot of people can't get
appointments if it's your first time um
you may not be able to sign up for an
appointment online the government
refreshes it every day around one
o'clock so go check then or pay 20
there's an app called appointment
scanner and this app you know whether it
was coveted vaccines or trying to find a
global entry it scans non-stop and it'll
alert you whenever there's a new
reservation i don't know how to tell you
this but i don't have global energy i
know you don't i'm so i'm trying i
believe in the mobile passport line if
you can't be my friend then please don't
be my enemy but the thing is the mobile
passport doesn't exist anymore yes so
that's the big kicker mobile passport
used to be a free alternative yeah the
government is so short-staffed they've
now so when you come back you should
literally apply before we go to rome
because you can actually get it before
we leave but so my thing is i have to go
downtown and interview can i do it
online you can do it so now they have
some zoom interviews that's what i'll do
and
if not just try like it's literally
worth it to go to jfk i'm telling you to
just get global entry because that when
i was going through from st bart's it
was a two-hour line it's all foreigners
and americans or global entry they don't
have the mobile line anymore that's
devastating because the mobile live it
was amazing great little kept secret but
it's no longer in most airports so get
your country and clear is really good
too yeah it's like a hundred dollars
clear will yeah clear will take you uh
to the front of the pre-check line yeah
um delta uh and it works at stadiums too
like yankee stadium yes msg yeah if um
for me delta paid for like half my
membership if you're a delta member it's
like 109 and then if each level it's
free for diamonds and then same thing
with united so if you've got elite
status um but clear and glow entry
pre-check gotta have um but before we
move on to the next story i just want to
say like i do understand why they didn't
invite caitlyn to the wedding but like
part of it part of that makes me really
sad like caitlyn was such a good stepdad
to them for like 20 years like when you
watch og seasons like
she was really like the father figure in
their life and so it does make me sad
even though i think they're justified
and not invited i hate to pivot but
what's beyonce there and why are there
no photos i don't know she happened to
be at the same hotel that all the guests
were staying at but she wasn't at the
wedding did you know that kris jenner
would have had a photo no of course
apparently she's really close with
travis and his kids oh so but i haven't
seen anything beyond the fact that she
landed and was staying at that hotel
randomly randomly i can't be a
coincidence yeah
um
okay we've got two more stories um and
the next couple stories are brought to
you by manscaped sweaty sac summer is
approaching wait is this why you invited
me on today yes because you have a
sweaty sack and this is my intervention
okay
sweaty sac summer is approaching and
it's time for you to prioritize the
comfort of your man's family jewels the
sponsor of today's episode manscape has
spent two years designing the
comfortable boxer briefs out there for
the men in your life we have had the
honor of testing out these new boxers
and all i can say is that it's the
softest fabric of any underwear and the
perfect loungewear for your night in or
sleepwear it comes from manscape so you
know it's a great gift for him let his
bulge breathe and get 20 off and free
shipping by using code toast at
manscaped.com so the micro modal fabric
is buttery soft breathable keeping his
cucumber cool you can walk run strut
these moisture wicker boxers breathe
without breaking a sweat the tagless
waistbands hug your body without digging
in and it lays flat against your skin to
reduce chafing so obviously these are
great for bed but if you are a lady who
likes to sleep in your man's underwear
these are fabulous they're like really
stretchy really breathable
the front fly open gives easy access
makes bathroom breaks quick and
efficient and you can choose from an
arrangement of designs colors sizes and
they range from small to 3xl get 20 off
and free shipping with the code toast at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code toast at
manscaped.com once the boxers 2.0 touch
his sack he'll never go back
all right we've got some food news
because i know you're a big snacker like
me
the ritz oreo cookie collab is blowing
our minds so when it comes to snacks
there are two obvious front runners
oreos and ritz peanut butter sandwich
crackers but what if you can't decide
between savory and sweet so the snack
wizards have a solution it is the new
ritz x oreo a franken cookie that's one
half buttery ritz and one half chocolate
oreo and it's double stuffed with both
peanut peanut butter flavored cream and
the original oreo cream it looks like a
practical joke in a cookie form but we
assure you it is no joke so oreo tweeted
that this was coming out 50 sweet 50
salty 100
delicious so it'll be available
on the 26th that is tomorrow we have to
get them for this weekend so basically
it is a it looks like an oreo but one is
ritz cracker a little bit of peanut
butter oreo cream oreo cracker i saw i
think evan ross cats or was it danny
pellegrino nuts he did a taste test and
it looks unique i mean this is literally
made for high people i mean let's just
cut it no it's just right when you can't
feed around the bush so high you need
like a pretzel and chocolate so you just
like need all savory and sweets and you
just shove this in your mouth it seems
like a lot when i was in high school i
once ate a double stuffed oreo betwixt
uh doritos ew that was so good
did you smoke a lot of pot in high
school not really but actually was the
turn of the century year 2000 and we all
thought we were gonna die right so
my friends and i
yeah we had gotten like a water bomb
when you slice off a two liter of pepsi
and like we made a bong all my friends
fell asleep before the year 2k so i was
high
as the world was about
eating oreos and doritos that's funny
while most people on this listening to
this podcast were like maybe born yeah i
was um i was actually with my in-laws
last night and they were talking about
the turn of the do you remember the y2k
new year no i was six years old but they
were talking about how like crazy it was
and they told me that
they were at this new year's eve party
it was like everyone was freaking out
but then it was like totally fine and
they left
and they were walking home and they saw
joan rivers walking into her apartment
iconic i know iconic do you think she
was wasted was she a big drinker um
that's actually a good question i don't
think so but like later in her life all
she did was work that like i don't think
she had time for it but imagine you know
in her heyday like when she was on the
letterman show and she was like you know
the girl about town i'm sure she did i
worked i'm friends with george
kotsiopoulos from fashion police and he
just when he speaks about joan he like
there's like a glint like a like a tear
in his he's like she was just as amazing
times 100 and he's like she she came off
mean but she he's like she was truly
like
like he told stories whenever his book
came out she like canceled her tour and
flew into l.a supported him like loved
him like a son like oh that's so sweet
joan he just yeah
just can't say enough good things about
her i love that because like i was just
watching her most recent special and she
got inducted into the netflix comedy
hall of fame and it's like
in these crazy times like who do we need
we need to voice everything we need joan
and we don't have her we don't so are
you going to try to if i find this will
you eat it 100 okay good me too
um fifth and final story i pulled from a
really kind of sickening up and coming
small little travel blog called the
pointsguy.com um and i want you to
explain it to us because there has been
a lot of uh hoopla
about this potential acquisition of
spirit buying jet blue or jet blue
buying space that blue buying spirit got
it so months ago spirit and frontier the
two ultra low-cost airlines in this
country decided to merge you know to
to create this mega cheap airline right
and so what's happened historically in
the us over the last like 15 years like
delta merged with northwest united and
continental
um
american and u.s airways so 80 and
actually southwest even acquired air
trans so 80 percent of flights in the us
are by these four carriers so the 20
that's left the spirits the frontiers
right alaska
it's so hard for them to compete because
to make a profitable airline you need to
have scale you need to have tons of
extra planes when something goes wrong
you need to have hubs and you know the
cost of maintenance on an airplane
decreases dramatically as you scale it
right so the only way to really become
profitable you know airfare is still
pretty cheap all things considered it so
it's like you've gotta
sketch it but it's not well
but we can get into that
hacks around and get cheaper fights but
anyway so jetblue was like oh wait once
spirit and frontier merge like there's
gonna be no one else really left for us
too right merge or how we're going to do
this so they basically came in and
offered and at first i was like no cause
i like jetblue mint is awesome jetblue
flights are great free dunkin donuts
free wi-fi big seats i fly coach on
jetblue that's why yeah
but recently they are one of the worst
airlines well because jetblue is too
small and like whenever there's like a
delay a rainstorm in orlando everything
goes into haywire so their point was if
we acquire spirit they actually have the
same type of planes we're to make their
planes nicer by adding in the jetblue
experience and this will actually keep
airfares lower because and and i
actually kind of agree with this at
first i thought it was a terrible idea
but what happens is with delta and
united
people who fly delta united
an american
don't look at frontier or spirit as
options so even if a spirit airlines is
150 cheaper than delta most people who
fly will go with that yeah so what
jetblue is saying is it actually will
benefit airfare because if we take over
and jeff blue becomes bigger we're
actually a competitor where people will
fly jet blue and now it's more
competitive pricing correct yes so i
actually i think it's a good idea me too
this article from most recently yeah
it's not happening so it's not happening
spirit said no jetblue then said okay
we're going to go straight to your
shareholders
um and it just doesn't look like it's
going to happen why why wouldn't spirit
want it spirits you know
you know when
in a capitalist world there's
you know the the powers that be at
spirit and frontier probably make a lot
more money with the deal that they have
even though shareholders might make more
because jetblue offered more right um so
there's all sorts of powers at play
but i actually i will say for the record
i wrote a newsletter saying i thought it
would be a bad idea because but if
jetblue actually took over all of
spirits planes and made them nicer
experiences
yeah i will say jetblue started flying
to london they brought the fares down
jetblue when they first started flying
to la with their mint brought fares down
so i stand jet blue and i'm kind of sad
for them that this isn't going to go
through i really like jet blue too but i
think you're right like the fact that
they're such a smaller airline is really
making them not even be an option for me
anymore because if you get even the
slightest delay like you're done no it's
so bad ben had it olivia had it like
literally leaving people jetblue's on
time performance is horrible what's the
airline with the best on time
performance delta
domestically delta hawaiian airlines
because they have perfect weather all
the time um
but yeah you know i i think delta and
united
are really good southwest and then
american americans pretty bad of the big
ones you know yeah i flew actually
american airlines recently for the first
time ever is that crazy and you didn't
really like it did you no actually i
mean
it's totally fine left on time clean
plane i i'm not a snob i really uh if
you leave on time i don't care well i
would care if i was in like the last
round but i i don't care like if you
leave on time and get me safely like
that's really all you need to do talk
about the elephant in the room we're
still in ongoing litigation with
americans that was the last time you
were on this i don't have an update for
you all today but it's still going on
there's still some stuff going on i get
like google alerts like you know i don't
run the points guy we're owned by red
ventures so the powers that beer
handling at this point in time and i
will update you all but i have to say on
the not like other girls tour i just
want to say thank you to all the girly
girls who came up screaming [ __ ]
american airlines it was hysterical your
support means the world and i actually
mean that yeah you actually mean that no
have we overused a phrase when we
actually have to disclaim it i truly
mean that that time that's a fair yeah
um okay well so let's do a few more
travel tips before we dive into deer
toasters we've got a big weekend coming
up people are traveling by car planes
trains automobiles what are your biggest
money-saving time-saving tips so we've
actually switched uh the points guys we
did a survey you know up until now
everyone's been worried about the kovid
traveling coveted now the number one
concern of consumers is pricing yeah so
from march to april flight prices went
up 20
almost which is the number in the
history of tracking flight prices was
number one month for increases and you
know we're all freaking out about eight
percent year-over-year inflation on
products and then in travel it's just
shooting up like crazy
so
that being said what i'll tell people is
you need to be flexible so if you don't
already use google flights teach
yourself today we have a blog post the
points guy how to maximize google
flights it's a free tool that google has
it lets you visualize all of the flights
and what i'll say to all of you is
think outside the box and there's
actually a feature on google flights
called explore map so what you can do is
you can put in i live in nashville i
want to travel these dates show me a map
of where the cheap fares are
so plan your trips where the deals are
yeah because there still are deals um
you know we've seen 150 you know quick
fair sales to hawaii
you know vegas is really cheap i mean
it's hot in the summer but you can still
have a fun time so you can find deals
but if you're dead set on going to
nashville a week before particularly you
know actually toasters message me
they're like i we were gonna have my
bachelorette there but flights are 600
and i can't do that right so
you know flight flight sales are hard to
find also europe is on sale so
how to beat travel inflation well the
u.s dollar
is almost equal to the euro right now
when i studied abroad 15 years ago or 20
you know 15 years ago
17. um
it was a dollar 40 for every euro so
super now it's like a dollar six a
dollar seven
so immediately there once you get to
europe portugal you can go to amazing
meals because they don't increase the
prices to just for americans right so
go to europe europe is like basically on
sale this summer flights you can get
cheap tickets there's carriers like
french b which is like a no-fills budget
airline but here's the thing i mean
especially if you're not freakishly tall
like me flights to europe these days are
like you know western europe but you're
five and a half six hours on a plane
have a couple cocktails take a benadryl
you'll wake up there sit in a cheap
little coach seat and then once you're
in europe i mean i'm from europe it's
it's thirty dollars on ryanair yeah
trains there's trains everywhere so go
to europe this summer versus paying 900
a night in miami yeah for something
you've already done a million times
totally and same thing like go off the
beaten path like mexico and costa rica
super expensive super crowded there's
amazing places nicaragua has sickening
beaches surfing colombia is cool
medellin which i've been is such an
artsy cool city cartagena i've been so
i'd say like push yourselves outside of
your comfort zone a little bit um versus
just going where everyone else is going
for memorial day yeah a lot of people do
driving trips what are your best tips
for like rental cars and stuff yes so
uh first of all with gas and even if
you're not traveling gas buddy is an app
that'll actually sniff out like the
cheapest gas and especially when you're
on state lines it can drop dramatically
as we noticed in california when we were
obsessed with tickets
for gas we were dying um so gas buddy
also when you're booking rental cars my
friends there's still
uh a shortage so book directly when
possible with the with the rental car
company kayak correct kayak whenever you
involve kayak unless you're getting a
way bigger deal even with flights
because when a flight gets you know
canceled the airline you wait four hours
and they're like oh you have to call
kayak kayak says call the airline you
know so and kayak like try opening up a
kayak tab without 55 other tabs yeah
it's so frustrating um so book directly
there's also a site called auto slash
which uh scans all the different car
rentals and then it'll actually rebook
you if the price drops which is pretty
cool that is nice auto slash it's been
around for a while it's free to use and
they automatically rebook you
um and also you know traffic roads are
going to be really traffic google maps
has a great feature which will actually
let you chart out a route at different
times of the day so traffic patterns
especially from the pandemic now are not
the same in every city yeah so like if
you're trying to do a road trip and
trying to figure out when to leave look
at google maps and put in the time it's
a nice little feature yeah and generally
and also with flights
i know a lot of us are not morning
people but the the flights that leave
the most on time are first flights in
the morning so suck it up get on that
flight the chances of you leaving and
also do not book tight layovers you know
when you're searching for tickets online
it'll often you know usually it's 45
minutes is the minimum the airlines have
what happens is you're going to be
running to your gate there are delays we
flew home from la and where our plane
sat for almost two hours on the runway
you imagine if you had a connecting
flight to europe you'd be panicked the
whole time so this summer do not give
yourself a tight connection because
you're gonna miss it and the thing is
flights are sold out so when you're in
charlotte trying to get a connection and
then you're going to aruba you're not
going to leave for three days so you
know suck it up build a three-hour
connection in you know get use your amex
platinum go to the centurion lounge
and that's just like my overall tip like
leave with more time leave with a good
attitude and please do not take your
frustrations out on airline employees
attitude is everything because if you
like go into a travel day like annoyed
stressed out every little even if it's
like a 20 minute delay like it'll bother
you so much and that's not good for your
mental health and yes agreed like some
of the [ __ ] i see like just traveling
for toward the way people are so [ __ ]
rude like you should be kicked off the
plane immediately if you are that rude
yeah it's disgusting yeah and it's not
these people's fault totally i mean
trust me like the gate agent working
that flight
she wants your flight gone asap you know
like they get graded you know they get
so like when there's a tornado outside
of laguardia and you're screaming at
them that you need to go on your cruise
like just take a chill pill okay
good one
um okay well thank you for that i hope
everyone was writing that down um and
are you free to join me for some dear
toasters uh 100 are you ready to help
some troubled youth yeah
all right dear toasters is brought to
you by hungry roots sometimes there's
nothing easier than ordering takeout for
dinner it feels easy but it's super
expensive and on the other hand just
thinking about grocery shopping and
having to play what's for dinner game is
exhausting so if you eat grocery
shopping or simply don't have the time
hungry root is here to help the easiest
way to get fresh high quality food
delivered to your door they've got
healthy groceries for and simple recipes
all in one place a fun short quiz is all
hungry root needs to get to know you
your goals and how you like to eat are
you gluten free noted do you like sweets
they'll keep it in top of mind and get
to work hungry root will recommend
groceries they think you'll love take
their suggestions or choose whatever you
want from their fresh produce high
quality meat and seafood they have
pantry staples and all the healthy
snacks and sweets you'll ever need
you're not just getting your weekly
grocery haul you can also shop thousands
of simple recipes that actually put your
food to use so everything hungry root
offers follows a simple standard it has
to be delicious quick to prepare and
made from whole trusted ingredients
right now hungry root is offering the
morning toast listeners 30 off your
first delivery and a free gift with
delivery just go to hungryroot.comtoast
to get 30 off your first delivery and
choose your free gift that's
hungryroot.com
toast don't forget to use that link okay
ready
dear claudia and brian i'm writing in
because i'm expecting my first child due
at the beginning of november and i need
your help today my mother-in-law came
over to kindly drop off some food at our
house and she mentioned that i shouldn't
make plans on labor day because that's
when she's planning my baby shower and i
have two problems with this the first is
that i'm very introverted and i
literally cannot handle having attention
on me i even had a very small wedding
immediate family only for that reason
two is that my mother-in-law is a lot
she and her five sisters are always up
in my business doing things that make me
uncomfortable making comments about my
body grabbing my belly my mother-in-law
even said labor day weekend would be the
best time for the shower because i
wouldn't be too heavy
at that stage in the pregnancy what the
[ __ ] is it rude if i tell her i don't
want a baby shower i know it would mean
a lot to her but it's my pregnancy and i
don't want to have an event where i'm
just getting picked apart and made
uncomfortable by her and her five
sisters i have a great relationship with
my mother-in-law she always means well
but i'm just uncomfortable with the idea
of a baby shower in general thank you in
advance for your help i promise to send
a follow-up whether i have to do this
god forsaken baby shower or confront my
mother-in-law sincerely a toaster who
prefers to stay out of the spotlight all
right well as two girls who hate the
spotlight we totally
totally relate to this i think so i have
11 nieces and nephews and three siblings
lots of dynamics um all good dynamics
lots of in-laws um what i will say is
it's important for you to set boundaries
now because when the baby comes and if
your mother-in-law just it's i see this
so much not necessarily my family but
like with people you know new mothers
hormonal and just stressed and when
there's not boundaries set with the baby
and you know grandma's love you know
everything every gram i talked to is
like it's so amazing it's the best thing
but you have to set the boundaries now
and that whole body shaming stuff is
ridiculous ridiculous the number one
thing you need to focus on is your
little baby congratulations yes i
totally agree with you boundaries are so
important and like it's when the baby's
here like it might be too late to set
those boundaries also can we have a
discussion about people stealing other
people's holidays
totally i mean i've been to some fun new
year's weddings but new year's is my
favorite holiday okay i just want to say
though you know olivia got married on
new year's and it was
the best time and i haven't had a better
new year since
i know and everyone who was there was
like thank god like try going to a new
year's party getting a drink no we're at
a wedding it's open bar like it was
really it was everyone who was there i
don't think they were just blowing smoke
up my ass they were like
if they happen to be in town if you
aren't in town you don't have to come
but if you're in town and there's a
wedding it's kind of ideal as long as
you like the people yeah okay so i just
i agree i'll yield some ground there i
think like when people get married on
thanksgiving like that's a lot yeah like
they're like well it's a four day
weekend yeah because it's thanksgiving
yeah and i want to like just chill yeah
so i i agree with you there i also think
your advice of setting boundaries as
quickly as possible is the best do it in
a sweet way again i i i relate to your
mother-in-law more on this because i'm
not introverted and i have so many
sisters and we're always like
i definitely touch people's bellies like
when i'm not supposed to
some people are weird about the belly
and
i just i'm a belly toucher so yeah i
relate to the to the mom more but
boundaries are boundaries and you have
every right to set them especially like
if you're having a child absolutely all
right next up this one is so crazy i
read it before
hey guys i'm a huge fan i listen every
morning long story short my boyfriend
and i have been dating for five years we
were both servers at this restaurant
where we met he no longer works there
but i do now and i'm a manager my boss
who my boyfriend knows and they all work
together my boss and i are very close
and not in a weird way i've just worked
there for six years so we have a good
relationship well this morning my
boyfriend woke up to a text message from
my boss saying she deserves better than
you it was 1am and he was obviously
drunk my boss loves my boyfriend so i'm
not sure why he would have texted him
that my boyfriend's telling himself it
was an accidental text but i don't
believe that do i say something does he
say something i feel like i'm sorry i
need to start looking for a new job is
my boss in love with me or just being
overprotective please help a naive
toaster who has no idea what to do from
a delusional gay perspective i'm sensing
some gay he's trying to drive you away
from your boyfriend so he can swoop in
for the boyfriend okay that is like a
delusional case but let's let's play
okay so he's in love with the boyfriend
he's in love with the boy he's in love
with the boy with the little boy so he's
in love with the boy and he thinks the
best way of getting the boy is to tell
the boy that he's not good enough for
the girl yeah okay i thought it through
in your gay fantasy i totally i could
see it for sure but the way that i
read maybe this is a heteronormative
person this is my heteronormativity
i feel like this boss is obviously in
love with you
how cute a workplace romance
no no
don't [ __ ] where you sleep 100 don't you
where you eat oh my god is that what it
is eat or yeah eat i mean i guess you
shouldn't [ __ ] where you sleep either
but i believe especially not on a heated
bed
i believe the phrases don't [ __ ] where
you eat um and i don't [ __ ] where you
heat
that's good i like that
um
your boss is in love with you like yeah
i think you have to address the text
message for sure
i don't know
some things are really just but she
really loves her job she's been there
for six years she shouldn't have to
leave a great job because if she starts
if she like opens up the can of worms i
feel like that's gonna have to that's
gonna force her to leave but if she just
ignores it and like it can go back to
normal yeah then she won't have to leave
but if yeah i mean you're kicking the
can down the road i mean once again it's
boundaries like you have to set
boundaries hey you can't text my
boyfriend anything i'm sure it was a
mistake we're gonna drop it but like
because if he doesn't she doesn't say
anything then he's gonna assume
obviously she knows and she didn't say
anything so he'll delusionally be like
well clearly i texted and told her
boyfriend to back off she didn't say
anything to me
she might love me like literally that's
how men think yeah so to like nip it and
be like hey i don't know what that was
i'm assuming it was a mistake but like
just know you can never text him yeah
that's fair actually but you if you do
that you have to be really stern and
it's hard to be stern no but with yours
it's better to put the boundary now than
literally letting this person think this
delusion right yeah
wow
she's being chased after two men how
exciting are we good at boundaries
uh with each other no
with anyone else who tries to enter our
little love our love bubble yes we got
the iron bubble
all right third and final one and it
comes with a photo hey girlies longtime
toaster first time writer i need some
serious but not so serious help i'm
moving in with my boyfriend and i'm so
excited he is a p john a literal angel
however our taste in furniture and home
decor just does not add up i'm very
neutral cozy vibes and he is whatever is
cheap slash passed down to him vibes
teresa
[Laughter]
he's pretty much given me creative
control over the whole apartment but the
only thing he won't budge on is this
heinous chair there's a picture attached
it's big and it's red and it's ugly he
says it's a lazy boy and good quality so
he doesn't want to get rid of it i
mentioned reupholstering it and he
wasn't
fond of that idea what do i do about
this damn chair it's so not the vibe
it's ruining my life do i tell him that
i hate it or do i tuck it away in the
guest bedroom here is the picture of the
chair and we will be posting the chair
on our instagram so everyone can go look
at it okay
it's really unique it's unique it's uh a
coat of many colors the dolly parton
song
the dolly parton it's also that it's in
the bible the code of many colors oh
really the technical the dream code i
had no idea um
did you go to church on sundays as a kid
every sunday but catholic mass is the
most boring thing and like you would
hate it you have to kneel oh
no don't get me wrong jewish synagogue
either
okay so i will say this in life you have
to make compromises and if this means
something to him and he let you have
full reign don't be a monster and
you should just make a joke out of this
and also look at this chair as a symbol
of like your love for him like i love
this guy so much he wanted this and you
gave it to him okay can i offer an
alternative yeah because if it is a good
chair like from lazy boy have it
reupholstered there's nothing wrong with
the chair except the fabric so throw a
blanket on top yeah so i actually am
redoing my house i have reupholstered
sofas so many times it literally brings
them back to life it's amazing so i
would be like
fun about it like make this like instead
of making it a big deal and like digging
into his taste or design since he let
you do so much be like i love the chair
like i love that you love it can we or
maybe like even get it for him as a gift
like reupholstered yeah look i got yours
but if he pushes back and he's like no i
really like it the way it is yeah i
think in life you just gotta like if
this take your battles pick your battles
and
i mean it's funny no it's not ugly
especially if i'm understanding her vibe
is like nude yeah if if he's so by the
way bring up totally the fact of
reupholstering it it's not expensive get
just like a nude suede it'll go with
your vibe and the chair shape is fine
like the legs are a little ugly but it's
fine it's just the pattern on the on the
material unique but if he says like no i
love this pattern which i doubt he'll
say what guy is like i love his pattern
yeah yeah so if he says that then drop
it because he's giving you this is the
one thing he wants you have to accept it
um but reupholstering i think is the
answer here i don't think he'll care
that that you changed
make just make sure it's like a really
soft yeah oh i love this and then you'll
end up liking the chair more than him
and everyone wins everyone wins so that
was your toasters if you ever have a
problem you want to write in to us it's
dear toasters gmail.com and we will
always keep your [ __ ] anonymous um
that's our show ryan you are a godsend
for coming on such short notice i
appreciate you more than life the
toasters love you and in exchange for
you being here the toasters are gonna
follow you on instagram leave nice
comments about how sexy you are and send
all their gay friends to your dms does
that work for you
that works for me
um i'm just excited to spend memorial
day with you
and i hope everyone has amazing safe
travels i do love if you have questions
dm me i usually try to get to as many as
possible but travel safe this summer
travel with a good attitude yes with
good group of girlies and use your
points and miles a lot of us a lot of
you have points just use them take money
off the table by saving and like splurge
a little bit do you not believe in
points hoarding i do not believe in
points hoarding they lose value over
time i don't believe in like using them
for gift cards but you know
if you have a trip and you have the
points and the good thing about when you
use points now you can get all your
points back versus getting a crappy
voucher when you pay for tickets oh you
can yeah you probably on almost every
airline they'll give you all your points
and miles back up until like the last
minute so if you get covet or just don't
want to go you get all your points back
it should always have been that way you
should yeah but oh that's fabulous yeah
so use your points
on instagram
at brian kelly thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning chose the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube to subscribe and give this video
a thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
already know box all the places so if
you listen to podcasts find us morning
toast leave a five star view about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are have
an amazing hump day and we'll see you
tomorrow hopefully with jackie but if
not i have a backup i have a backup love
you bye
you